bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de rtl france installé dans le cadre du
forum de saint pétersbourg le forum
économique qui a réouvert ses portes
cette année après une année
d'interruption pour cause de covin avec
nous pour en parler justement de cette
ambiance de la façon dont les relations
économiques sociales et financières
s'organise entre les différents pays
jean pierre semard bonjour bonjour
ancien banquier français qu'on connaît
anciens politique conseiller politique
de nicolas sarkozy pour les affaires
avec la russie notamment
et aujourd'hui conseiller d'un certain
nombre de groupes français qui veulent
ou qui travaillent en russie avec la
contrepartie parce que vous travaillez
aussi pour les groupes russes qu'ils
veulent et qui travaillent en france
comment est l'ambiance alors l'ambiance
elle l'est elle est en fait il ya deux
mois elle est moyenne
il ya deux mondes il ya le monde des
affaires des entreprises est aujourd'hui
le forum leproux ya beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprises y avait ce matin panel de
chefs d'entreprises français parmi les
plus prestigieux les plus grandes total
société générale chutait électrique ça
c'est la réalité les avaient ils veulent
travailler y travaillent et sont
positifs et les russes de leur côté font
de même et d'ailleurs ici à plus deux
mythes de 2000 chefs d'entreprise venus
du monde entier y compris bien sûr les
aurons fait un pas que les français et
de l'autre côté on a des relations
politiques qui sont pas bonnes
il faut dire la vérité ce cas chez les
petits doigts elles sont c'est une sorte
de nouvelle guerre froide avec les
sanctions et très honnêtement ça
n'empêche pas le business la preuve
mais c'est vrai que sans calamine et ça
freine le développement du business
alors ça peut chez les bulls das même si
les sanctions précédentes ont été à peu
près assumer
et j'irai sent bien que mal le coït a
fait plus de mal que les sanctions puis
les sanctions les sanctions quand même
des sanctions ont pénalisé pas seulement
la russie en premier lieu l'europe et la
france et la france parce qu'en fait nos
exportations russes y ont baissé
la russie s'est tournée petit à petit h
et pousse à le faire sur la chine
donc au lieu de prendre nos technologies
en europe et en france ils les prennent
en chine
on est en train de pousser la première
réserve mondiale d'énergie le plus grand
pays du monde la première réserve d'eau
potable la plus grande forêt du monde le
pétrole a sur la chine cet immense
atelier de transformation ac ou encore
pour un moment là tivement bas et
compétitif les américains n'ont pas trop
les américains dans leur business sont
très présents et les américains sont
présents comme d'habitude je viens
discuter que des amériques à l'instant
et regarde comment faire du business
trop content qu'ils font de freiner le
nôtre bien entendu mais ça on peut pas
leur reprocher faut pas reprocher à se
reprocher à nous de ne pas faire
autrement c'est à dire d'arrêter sur le
plan européen et la france 2 et moteurs
ces sanctions parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya
quand même une nouvelle dynamique
on est j'espère posco bible a sorti du
coc libre c'est le thème de ce forum
c'est à dire la nouvelle nerfs
le low carbon la décolonisation de
l'économie ils ont besoin de
technologies il faut décarbonés
l'économie et la production d'énergie
russe
et ça c'est notre rôle nous attendent on
a besoin d'eux ils ont besoin de nous et
ça les sanctions c'est un boulet au pied
dont on doit se passer
on parle même sanction passé mais ce qui
ce qui piège et qui plombe un peu le
climat c'est les menaces de nouvelles
sanctions
oui les menaces de nouvelles sanctions
au niveau du système de financement et
les solutions nouvelles et répété c'est
comme les punitions pour les enfants
vous domaine sont totalement inefficaces
personne n'y croit moi je crois que je
crois que la russie petit à petit
devient de plus en plus insensible à ces
sanctions
la résilience de la russie a été prouvé
dans l'histoire on parlera bontin
napoléon la deuxième guerre mondiale
pour le voir est-ce que sa part 600 g
iii vie serait prête techniquement à
surmonter une sanction grave sur les
systèmes de paiements internationaux
pour être très franc avec vous je suis
convaincu de la russie aujourd'hui peu a
les moyens de surmonter toutes les
sanctions qui peuvent venir pourquoi
parce que c'est un immense espace
c'est un immense pays qui au pire du
pire peut être drôle partie bien sûr pas
surtout à la banque une nouveauté mais
sur sa survie peut être autonome
deuxièmement c'est la porte sur l'asie
est aujourd'hui la coopération que la
chine est très forte et pas seulement
que la chine
mais est ce qu'on appelle les brics par
erreur dans les pays comme dans le pot
aujourd'hui dans le poids dans le pib
moyen des ténors plus fort que l'europe
est donc aujourd'hui c'est pour nous
autres on isole pas la russie en s'isole
nous mêmes mais aussi sommes nous mêmes
par une espèce de fidélité à la doctrine
américaine les américains la première
économie du monde sont nos partenaires
on ne continue à avoir des des
réalisations avec eux des relations
équilibrées et forte à laquelle rome
imposer ses vues et on doit discuter de
nos intérêts ne sont pas à la remorque
des états unis et pour nous et ça c'est
la politique gaullienne
il ya très longtemps mais ça n'a pas
changé qui est que cette europe de
l'atlantique à l'oural et puis jusqu au
kamchatka vladivostok j est une réalité
d'ailleurs biographiquement si on
regarde bien au moment où on parle de
co2 de l'europe géographique sans la
russie n'est pas l'europe
géographiquement l'europe jusqu'à
l'oural
en conséquence cette idée de couper le
continent de kits une vie américaine
ouah l'hégémonisme giral de gaulle
pensait que l'europe allait dessus de
l'atlantique alors absolument est donc
aujourd'hui l'idée de couper cette
grande europe en deux est une idée
américaine parce qu'à partir de ce
moment là imaginer la puissance d'une
coopération économique euro russe
on a fait des rapports à une époque à
l'initiative et prendre la république
française d'époque et russe et je vous
signale qu'il ya douze ans et ça c'est
pas mignon mais jean-pierre thomas
expliquez moi comment se fait-il que la
france ait changé un petit peu
d'attitude
il ya deux ans lorsque le président
macro est venu à moscou il a même parlé
d'une panne élargissement de l'euro
qu'il fallait étudier
ils appellent pour citer la phrase du
général de gaulle le président mao jour
d'hui il en est vraiment plus question
le président macro est plein de bonnes
intentions
la visite au trianon était parfait peu
sud y est enfin après olemps nous
repartons dans la voie de la coopération
le discours devant les ambassadeurs sur
l'état profond et excellent jeu les
mêmes je le rappelle fait imprimer pour
voir détails ce cas mais on n'a fait
strictement tout le contraire en même
temps et donc en même temps c'est
difficile parce que les russes sont des
gens c'est carré donc il vaut mieux leur
dire la vérité tout de suite et est l
idée aujourd'hui c'est qu'on ne
coopèrent pas du tout dans laxe qu'on a
dit les regarder sur north stream
premièrement on soutient la position un
peu américaine de dire à north stream
c'est pas le tracé et c'est donc on ne
soutient pas vraiment relate mme merkel
puis maintenant que je suis issu
américaines évoluent
eh bien on est tout seul ça c'est ce qui
va nous arriver si on continue sur le
plan économique c'est à dire que les
allemands afin qu'un finalement se
mettent d'accord
nous on n'a pas soutenu nos amis russes
ou culturellement historiquement des
quatre ailiers il nous aime bien malgré
tout la famille pour l'ont fait et je
vais dire ça c'est une stratégie qui
paye bas on est isolé et un jour les
etats unis qui sont nos partenaires
bien entendu c'est pas le sujet on
travaille avec eux ils pensent à eux
d'abord ce qui est logique on ne peut
pas leur reprocher mais si on se coupe
de la russie états unis s'occupant de
même on va travailler avec qui donc
l'europe sera isolé aujourd'hui le
problème
je pense que les russes n'ont pas
vraiment d'interlocuteurs en novembre
ont pas vraiment un interlocuteur de
poids pendant un dossier qui est très
présent ici cette année un dossier qui
est le dossier de la protection
d'environnement de la décarbonisation d
énergie et d une rose à hong hong et
corps humain peu surpris parce que on a
un occident qui s'y très préoccupé par
les actionnaires les syndicats les
consommateurs veulent de green partout
les écologistes font pression et on
n'avait pas le sentiment que la russie
était très concernés mais nous vendre du
pétrole et du gaz tel qu'il était donc
je vous le disais à changer à ça quand
tu vois que vous êtes un fin observateur
c'est exactement ça seulement nous on
parle nous on parle beaucoup on fait et
ce matin tout le monde y compris des
français reconnaissait qu'on ne fait pas
assez
ici par le mois mais démarre très vite
songer qui met 5 milliards de dollars
sur le redressement du déchet on est
dans tous les halls 1 toutes les régions
sur cinq ans avec une agence fédérale
toute nouvelle qui vient d'être créée
moscou vient de émettre une obligation
de green bones pour financer des cars
bonnement l'économie et se financer en
même temps les oblasts dans les régions
je vienne en sibérie récemment
réfléchissent à la forêt première forêt
du monde 1 % la surface mondiale sont
effectivement porteur de beaucoup
beaucoup de crédits carbone
c'est une 50 dollars la tonne c'est une
richesse et ça permet d'investir dans la
détermination de financer des projets
décarbonisation ce forum est entièrement
centré beaucoup plus je ne savais pas
sur ce tales est aujourd'hui tous les
ministres membres du gouvernements et
d'entreprises russes ont l'air d'aller
très vite
alors bien entendu partent de loin il ya
beaucoup à faire mais je pense qu'ils
vont très bad de loin mais il suscite en
train de transférer une partie de leur
état en chine où la chine se préoccupe
pas trop ça nous on a on a besoin je
pense que c'est notre intérêt c'est le
leur aussi de non pas les aider parce
qu'en fait tu peux faire une grande
partie sans nous mon intérêt à coopérer
veolia le numéro un mondial des déchets
de l'eau aujourd'hui de pouvoir procéder
à des choses en russie de pouvoir
coopérer sur ces grands projets et relie
tizi le patron d'air liquide ce matin a
expliqué sur l'oxygène déjà les choses
sont en place
bouya nayl patronne n'est pas en quoi
total pourquoi total est aussi présent
celle du pétrole ils achètent du gaz
6 mondial en france son étendard
aujourd'hui c'est c'est le green c'est
les énergies naturelles total un patron
for wii qui va dans la bonne direction
et le groupe même effort
et si indécent denrées nécessaires qui
aimait bien la russie et qui était très
souvent réussi dans tous ses forums
total a non seulement engagé des
capitaux importants transférer de la
technologie qui jouez la carte russe
dans la coopération respectant les
règles d'une sanction etc
et en plus sordide vis en train de
prendre un virage considérable sur la
production d'énergie électrique totale
est en train de créer une nouvelle
société qui va faire de la production
d'énergie électrique alternatives au
pétrole et au gaz
l'idée du patron de total est excellente
c'est aujourd'hui et il le dit je
reprends sa frappe
nous allons aider les russes à
décarbonés l'économie et la production
d'énergie russe
c'est ça notre rôle si on le comprend
les sanctions sont un boulet au pied
dont on n'a pas besoin donc ça n'a aucun
sens blancs de cow perec la russie là
dessus parce que la pollution et les
global elle s'arrête pas sur un mur
administratives entre l'union européenne
à la lumière des progrès sur le co2 avec
le vent et loyal donc on le sait depuis
très loin france représente en tout cas
ce n'est pas de prendre nous y serons en
france que ce pays est immense et le
plus grand pays du monde peut pas se
passer en surface au niveau de l'os est
la première réserve d'eau douce du monde
c'est le baïkal réserve de capacité à
besoins de s'industrialiser
il ya besoin de diversifier son activité
parce qu'elle est quand même très très
très axé l'énergie et donc c'est pas
forcément un pays dont on pouvait penser
a priori qu'il était directement
concerné par la décarbonisation je pense
et je veux croire je pense qu on
sincèrement le verra dans le discours du
président poutine demain je pense que
ils ont compris ils ont compris ils
avaient compris mais je crois qu'ils
viennent de décider d'y aller très fort
et très vite
c'est un tournant et je pense que
d'ailleurs là-dessus ils peuvent
construire aussi une sorte d'économie
nouvel impôt sco vite parce que la
russie l'an prochain la russie coin
souvent depuis le lycée ou et moi on a
appris la russie ne transforme pas ces
matières premières comme ça qu'elle est
l'occasion de démontrer le contraire
c'est aussi la nouvelle green economy
donc je pense qu'ils ont compris tout ça
et je pense ne pas me tromper on en
reparlera ils vont aller très vite
les concurrents français sont allemands
également sont pas en grande forme sur
les marchés également ses internationaux
sont très présents réf
oui mais ils sont tant ils sont ils sont
aussi en phase d'interrogation par
rapport à tout ce dont on parle de
l'écologie est ce que vous prévoyez vous
est ce que vous faites des scénarios sur
la primaire qu'elle paraisse
d'après marc l on ne sait pas encore une
fois être prudent qui sera le patron le
chancelier est ce que ce sera maire est
ce que ce sera modéré centre modéré on
verra mais je pense que l'allemagne peut
être résistantes sur ces sujets si les
grilles beaucoup plus modéré que les
nôtres plus entre 36 sont vraiment
reprennent le manche en allemagne on
verra bien mais l'allemagne sur le plan
si je voudrais forces avenir on donne
allemagne en exemple toujours en france
mais est ce que l'allemagne ait
véritablement prête à affronter assumer
la préco vide au niveau de son industrie
j'en suis pas si sûr
ah non dans son industrie automobile je
n'entends pas ce n'est pas aussi
puissante qu'on le dit il est plus
difficile de transformer des premiers
pays fort et efficace comme l'allemagne
ou même nous ce matin parce qu'on a
beaucoup de changements faire pour
passer dans une économie différente de
pays qui sont plus nouveau même si sur
le plan économique et qui ont beaucoup à
faire mais qui par beaucoup plus de du
départ est donc de faire bien dès le
départ c'est plus facile que de refaire
avec du vieux et ce sera plus à
transition peut être plus facile sur ces
pays +9 des faits de briques sans
questionnement pouvez-vous dire si on a
besoin d'explications que la france a
des atouts pour rentrer pour conquérir
un pays comme industrie parce que l'art
enregistré parce que la france a des
crampes lors aux mondiaux industriels
les grandes entreprises françaises
prévoient la leyre et spatiales renoir
oui oui
lortie sur la nouvelle économie veolia
air liquide angie en digital on n'est
pas très très très simple c'est des
grands c'est des grands leaders mondiaux
et aux liens ce numéro mais oui air
liquide très puissant sur un triptyque
nos légionnaires enrique est très bon
seiler électrique est très bon sur le
digital
comment rendre beaucoup plus efficace
tout ce qui est la gestion des sociétés
les immeubles intelligents loca ramoneda
on a très bon niveau je pense la france
à saint pierre à apporter à l'édifice
si c'est pas nous ce sera 12 la
confrontation des images est importante
les avis des opinions publiques le
problème c'est que si nos gouvernants
suivre l'opinion publique
au lieu d'essayer d'orienter d'expliquer
n'emmener avec l'opinion publique c'est
le rôle d'un leader
on va dans le mur
et ça le rôle d'un politique c'est pas
de suivre notre opposé des ide guider le
troupeau est en général pour se
raccrocher lee présidence et qui montre
la vo explique où il va mais si
simplement une mesure qui regarde tous
les matins où elle troupeau pour le
suivre c'est ça sur la russie je suis ce
qu'on appelle l'opinion est ce que ce
n'est pas l'autre magnon non je vous le
dis parce que vous êtes mais est-ce que
bons journalistes savent par exemple que
leur image et passe si bien reçu que sa
part le bilan et le renard parce qu'il
ya divorce entre l'opinion publique de
la bonne france de base
j'aime bien la russie parce que
historiquement c'est nos amis et d'un
autre délit existe une culture puis y
est tellement proches voilà les deux
pieds de france viendra syrienne et
gabriela france politique une partie
médiatique
quelle mauvaise idée sur la russie qui
pas qu'ils appartiennent sorte de
prêt-à-penser tout fait et qu'il n'est
pas juste regarder l'évolution de moscou
tous ceux qui viennent à moscou qui ne
sont pas venus depuis cinq ou six ans
sans réellement étonné de l'évolution
sur le plan écologique les maisons bien
vous qui avez fait de la politique parce
que vous avez fait de la politique on ne
peut quand même pas d'un côté dire bombe
a quitté la politique ça appartient à la
politique ça c'est propre logique et
nous ont fait de l'économie
on fait du business on fait des affaires
la dépendance et le grand écart qu'un
jour ou l'autre n'est plus possible et
je pense qu'on est arrivé à la limite de
cet exode parce que par politesse
et moi je m'exprime librement avec vous
j'ai toujours fait comme ça c'est un
choix mais venir beaucoup de gens par
politesse gentillesse ne disent rien il
veut très bien que c'est un frein vous
savez quand vous conseiller une
entreprise dont le dirigeant décidé de
coopérer que la russie on y va mais le
service qu'en pleine de l'entreprise
quand il se saisit du sujet avec les
lois et l'heure la priorité aux lois
américaines et blocs tôt donc
aujourd'hui on arrive à un système qui
est bloquant ça c'est un sujet qu'il
faut régler
jean-pierre thomas merci beaucoup
merci à vous rappelle que vous êtes
peut-être un de ceux qui en france
connaît le mieux les ressorts et les
relations entre la france et la russie
grand l'interview on la retrouve sur le
replay sur les sites internet sur les
réseaux sociaux on la retrouve bien sûr
sur le site de l' art écran certes
transport tv et puis nous on se retrouve
très bientôt
[Musique]